there's a fellow who uh made a video and
he criticizes our site
our notion of science our notion of
physics and i'm going to be addressing
each one of his points and the point he
made
one of the points he made and i'm going
to talk about today is whether if you
have a phd right does that mean that you
understand physics
and so let me put them on here give me a
second okay let me turn this follow on
here it goes listen carefully
the issue to be resolved in this
rebuttal is
does having a phd in mathematical
physics imply that the individual
understands physics
well if you have a phd you're far more
likely to understand the subject that
you have a phd in than someone who
doesn't have a phd in that subject if
you've got a phd that at least shows
that you have a decent understanding of
the subject because you do need a decent
understanding of the subject to be able
to get a phd
okay so the question is whether you need
a phd to understand or we can put it in
different terms we can say that a person
who has a phd for example in so-called
mathematical physics right uh whether he
can understand things better than you
or anyone else
and i take exactly the opposite view
okay here's my uh rundown of that okay
these are what i call the fallacies okay
first of all i think it's an easier for
an eight-year-old to understand physics
than it is for anyone who's gone through
high school or college
and you might say well that sounds
counter-intuitive
and let me tell you why because see when
you get to high school when you get to
college they start feeding your brain
okay and when we come out of there we
come out and believe me for example i'll
give you a good example uh we believe
that
electricity consists of the flow of
electron beads from one atom to the next
that's is what everybody thinks uh
electricity is and so if you give
someone a different version of that you
know it's already hardwired in his brain
he's not going to change his way of
thinking so easily on the other hand if
you take a
kid you know eight-year-old kid
and you teach him the right way or you
teach him a different way from the start
you know he's got no reason to believe
then that the you know electricity is
the flow of beats so that's that's the
key issue okay it's that uh in in high
school in college they start forming our
brains and then it's very hard to get
out of that i know i've been there done
that okay so i call that the fallacy of
authority and that's what this is what
it looks like you have uh you could say
big brother there or someone with a big
degree teaching you and you learn by
rote and then you repeat what this
fellow told you
you believe it in great measure because
if you want to make a career you know
you do a career out of it for example
physics well you're not going to get an
advisor unless
unless you know you follow the rules and
the rules is you have to suck up okay
that's the issue you know and i don't
know how you can get a degree unless you
at least
you know
follow the party line okay you have to
be able to recite the catechism that's
what it amounts to
i call that the fallacy of authority
anyways uh here you have some phds this
is what they believe here are some
examples okay they have proposed big
bang
black hole
particle at two places at once warp time
now how's that for for uh people who
have degrees
what uh phds right we're talking about
the highest degree here and if this is
what they came out with you know i mean
what does it tell you about them
and this is what you gotta think about
so the way i look at a degree does not
necessarily equal to understanding in
fact i think it's the other way around
if you have a degree typically it's
because you've been brainwashed in a
given direction and it's very very hard
for you to you know come out of that
and uh so you know just keep that in
mind when you go to college they
actually make you think in a given way
and
you know it's almost impossible for
people to come out of that then there's
the fallacy of democracy what i call uh
faucia democracy that's what it looks
like okay
everybody voting for a theory
and that's also more or less what's
happening at the college level
you know you have all these
mathematicians on planet earth and they
vote for a given theory and so people
say well it's been proven because all
these mathematicians believe in that
theory
okay and so you have uh
you know theory someone says you know
particularly in two places at once
and if everybody votes for that because
they studied quantum mechanics
and you say well you know that sounds uh
counterintuitive that doesn't sound very
irrational well they're going to say
that what you have to do is take a
course in college so that you're
brainwashed in the same direction so
yeah you've got that situation as well
and then uh the last one is what i call
the fallacy of tradition okay and that's
what that looks like okay here it is
that's a policy of transition you know
you you believe in stuff because that's
the way we've always done it
and a prime example are definitions
what people do with definitions is they
they you'll see them here on comments
that people make
and they go in there and they say look
uh this is the etymology of the word
i don't care what the etymology of the
word word is because those words were
created a long time ago maybe they come
from the latin from the greek from the
persian who knows from where
and they had a certain definition
centuries ago we've changed many of
those definitions throughout time you
know we've made uh we've given new
definitions to old words
that's happened but all those
definitions are really in the realm of
ordinary speech when you bring them into
science hopefully hopefully you restrict
their usage so that you know they don't
cover everything out there so that you
can't tell the difference between a and
b now you have to make sure that you
have a very crisp definition that you
can use consistently that's called
rational you know scientific
and uh so yeah the fallacy of tradition
primarily relates to um
definitions but it also the way we do
things one of the fallacies of
tradition also involves you know the
fact that um
we have this notion of the scientific
method of science that we have inherited
from the 17th century and we're not very
willing to change that we think we're on
the right track and it turns out that
not a single mathematician who follows
the so-called scientific method of the
17th century can tell you anything about
gravity they cannot tell you anything
about magnetism they can't tell you what
electricity is they can't tell you how
the atom behaves they can't tell you
what mediator we have for light
in other words they can't tell you
anything about the invisible intangible
uh entities and mechanisms that mother
nature and father universe use out there
but they've been following the
scientific method now what for 400 years
so they're not willing to change that
and in fact i had a case this week
i was interviewed on thursday by a
fellow from england
and so i told them up front that i have
a different notion of what science is i
have a different notion of what the
scientific method is and i told him up
front that he would be shocked because i
was going to delete from the scientific
method i was going to delete mathematics
and i'm going to delete also experiments
now he seemed to agree he kind of liked
the fact that i just you know took
mathematics out he didn't give me a
reason but he seemed to like that but
when we got to experiments he had big
troubles with that okay he said you know
you're going to remove experiments i
said yeah we don't need them uh we don't
do experiments in science we explain
them
and so i i really put them against the
wall on a given issue on a specific
issue and i said
you have um you know gravity you let go
of the pen i always do my little
experiment here let go of the pen and it
falls to the floor okay
you can't see or touch anything below or
above the pen
correct
and so the question is what experiment
are you going to use meaning see touch
right eyes hands what experiment are you
going to run to
elucidate
the
first the
entity that mediates gravity and second
be able to explain it because you
proposed an entity that we can see or
touch
so there is no way there's no experiment
you can run to detect the invisible
intangible the only way is to use the
mind you visualize and you try to
imagine how mother nature father
universe devil the god whoever you
believe in how they could be doing this
magic trick okay there is no experiment
you can run in the lab to detect
whatever is causing gravity and that's
just one example and so you know i i
told this fellow this and again here we
have the fallacy of uh all these
fallacies come back the tradition uh
democracy and specifically you know the
the uh one the uh one of authority
people believe in authority this is what
they've been drilled with in high school
and college and this is what they
regurgitate you know as again the party
line that's all it is that's what it
comes down to
and so
this fella he had troubles with that and
what was interesting that um
we debated a little bit about some of
the definitions okay and these are some
of the definitions i found in his site
afterwards i checked his site and these
are some of the definitions he's got out
there and the the two that we're missing
are the two most important ones meaning
he wasn't even on track on figuring out
what are the most important definitions
that we need at least for the purposes
of physics and here let me show you what
definitions he proposed what i want you
to notice is that he mentions these
words
specifically the word exist but he never
defines it
but uh so when i tried to define exist
he had a problem with that because it
was contrary to what he believed in uh
he apparently was an atheist and he had
a problem with me saying that uh you
know an atheist
was not a rational individual because an
atheist talks about the non-belief of
god or that he doesn't believe that god
exists and that i told him there's an
irrational statement it's an irrational
statement because he doesn't understand
what the word exist means and physics is
the science of existence
so that's how it all works so here are
his definitions okay he says believe to
accept something as true so he uses
words such as true false you'll find it
in there i underline some of these what
is knowledge fact
truth okay
he talks about reality what is reality
well you look it up there that right at
the bottom reality is it means uh
reality is that which exists well
unfortunately reality is a synonym of
exists so he hasn't defined the word
reality what he's done is he put a
synonym and uh and he goes around in
circles because again he hasn't defined
what exists means so uh this is the
issue and one of the issues that
was interesting about his definitions in
that is that he uh referenced ayn rand
ein rand as some caller i call her ain
rand okay and when he mentioned there
are two that are really unimportant
they're not important as uh for example
entity and exist but he put in their
concept okay he said a constant is a
mental integration of two or more units
possessing the same distinguishing
characteristics with their particular
measurements omitted they are isolated
by a process of abstraction and united
by a specific definition
enran was very verbose and
and she made nonsense of the word
concept the other one is reason
and the problem is that reason uh she
demanded is the faculty that identifies
and integrates the material provided by
man's senses
thinking is the process logic is the
method so enran thought that senses had
something to do with reason whether
you're sensible right whether you're
sound whether your argument is sound and
when you look up all these words uh you
know they're all
synonyms sound sensible reason rational
they're all synonyms so she never
defined the word because you use
synonyms to define them okay you can't
do that in science besides you synonyms
are outlawed because a synonym is
a circular definition or what i call no
definition at all okay
and uh this is another one and he had
here he because he um
as well suggested that there are things
that we know and i said we know nothing
because no means to believe when someone
knows
he believes he believes for sure he's
convinced of whatever he believes in
that's called knowledge his knowledge
could be different than my knowledge so
he gave me an example and he said well
we know
we know
that water boils at 100 degrees
okay
and so this is the example that water
boils at 100 degrees
and there's a couple problems here the
first one is that i'm gonna take the i'm
gonna play devil's advocate okay
and i'm gonna say uh no water does not
boil at 100 degrees and he said no
let me prove it to you let me show you
look we put some water here i heat it to
100 degrees and put and i say i don't
believe you
i don't believe i don't know your
knowledge
i i disbelieve you and he goes into no
but listen let me show you let me prove
it to you here's the truth here's the
fact and i continue to say no no no no
no what's he going to do kill me
i mean there are people who simply will
not change their minds no matter what
experiment what proof you present and it
will continue to believe otherwise and
he didn't understand that nowadays is
what one person has okay and so that's
one issue the other issue is that water
boils at 100 degrees
that's not an explanation that's a
description that's a prediction he can
say look i did it a hundred times now i
can predict to you and i can run an
experiment where i prove to you that
water boils at 100 degrees
so far he hasn't explained anything all
he's done is describe what's going to
happen he hasn't told me why what causes
water to boil at 100 degrees
so i gave him
a truth a fact a proof right the whole
works
you know something that's been confirmed
by experiment i said look nasa ran
gravity probe b what was that i think
1971 okay i think it was 71 72
thereabouts anyways nasa ran this
experiment and what was the conclusion
what was the physical interpretation
for what they say is a com another yet
another confirmation of einstein's
theory okay what was the explanation
they said that the earth drags
uh drags time around itself it's known
as frame dragging okay and then we got a
little title for it because they're
saying that with respect to a given uh
frame frame of reference right uh
something changes they have these two
gyroscopes that change their position
out there and they say oh we confirmed
it and we proved it etc etc and so i
gave him that explanation i said look uh
nasa says that
earth as it spins it drags time around
itself which makes no sense whatsoever
from a physical point of view okay
mathematically we don't care we're
saying that the explanation they gave us
is is nonsense and he says well i don't
believe that let's see what do you mean
you don't believe it's knowledge we've
proven it through an experiment like you
said and he said no that knowledge i
don't believe i don't believe nasa
so so i mean again knowledge is what one
person believes okay the his neighbor
doesn't believe it okay
and he said but my knowledge is
justified you know that comes from plato
justified true belief okay and he said
but my what if it's justified what if i
have a justification for having that
knowledge and i said justified means
belief what is justified who justified
it the pope the dalai lama i mean who
justified it
justified means opinion belief so all he
said is he believes his belief that's
all he said when he says that his
knowledge is justified so no those
people who insist that knowledge is
different than belief well i want a
definition don't tell me that your
knowledge is different just tell me what
each one exactly means and i'll be glad
to tear it apart because to this day we
equate well we start we're still using
plato's definition and that one uh it
comes out as justified true belief
that's what knowledge is and all they're
saying is that your belief is justified
but what is justified to one human being
is unjustified to another and knowledge
comes down to being equal exactly equal
to believe there's no difference okay
experiment will not change that okay no
experiment will change that okay so so
uh what was this uh fellas uh
beef well the problem was when i said
that atheists are as irrational as
agnostics and as diaz or the theists
why why are these three groups uh
irrational
they're irrational because they never
defined the word exist so they argue in
circles one guy says i believe that god
exists and he presents all his proof the
other guy says i don't believe that god
exists and he presents all his arguments
and proofs and the agnostic says well i
don't know if god believes or
exists or not
i don't know what tests we can run i'm
not sure what arguments they have beyond
them you know they have like several
arguments but essentially it's a guy who
hasn't made up his mind he's on defense
and i'm saying all these three
individuals are irrational why are they
irrational well for that we we go back
to mrs ain rand okay maybe she can
clarify for us
why it's irrational here's a rand's uh
definition of entity first okay thing
what is a what is an object what is a
thing what is an entity she'd like the
word entity no problem we consider it a
synonym okay no of object end of uh
thing so where's the problem let's let's
look at her definition we'll find out
here it is okay she says entity okay and
she says to exist is to be something
and we have a problem there as you can
see uh uh she essentially was a
pupil uh a follower whether she knew it
or not of david hume and emmanuel kant
who said exactly the same thing in the
18th century because they couldn't tell
the difference between exist and a thing
or
exist in an object so she says to exist
this to be something absolutely not but
let's continue as distinguished from the
nothing of non-existence it is to be an
it is to be an entity of a specific
nature made of specific attributes and
this is where it goes wrong i want you
to listen to this because she
essentially uh synthesizes what most
people out there think a thing is okay
the development of human cognition
starts with the ability to what perceive
things in other words entities perceive
it's that perception word that
introduces the observer uh where we
don't need them and so she continued
says of man's five cognitive senses only
two provide them with the direct
awareness of entities sight and touch
exactly the ones that we kill we say
sight and touch have nothing to do with
physics okay we don't use sight and
touch when we theorize we have to kill
the observer we do it mafia style rub
the witness out that's the way it works
in science in order to perceive this
something he needs sight and or touch
okay so she's going to emphasize the
observer she's going to emphasize the
witness she says we need sight and we
need hands uh touch we need eyes and
hands it is by perceiving entities that
man perceives the universe okay so she
did emphasize uh that for entities for
things what you need is eyes and touch
and what is eyes and touch it's also
exist because exist is defined exactly
in the same way not only by ayn rand but
david hume and emmanuel kant okay and so
we move to existence which is what
concerns us because we're going to be
talking about the atheists who say that
they don't believe in god we are looking
at the theists and theists who say they
do believe in god and the agnostics who
say that they don't know whether to
believe or not and this is what ayn rand
had said about existence existence
exists
existence exists now how's that for a
definition and the act of grasping that
statement implies two corollary axioms
that something exists which one what
perceives
and that one exists possessing
consciousness consciousness being the
faculty of what perceiving that which
exists
all she did was chase her tail around if
nothing exists there can be no
consciousness
a consciousness with nothing to be
conscious of is a contradiction in terms
okay if that which you claim to perceive
does not exist what you possess is not
consciousness
whatever the degree of your knowledge
these two existence and consciousness
are axioms you cannot escape whether you
know the shape of a pebble or the
structure of the solar system the axioms
remain the same that it exists and that
you know it again knowledge introduced
together with existence and things
so she continues he says to exist is to
be something absolutely not as
distinguished from the nothing nothing
of x non-existence the greatest of
philosophers she was referring to
aristotle has stated the formula
defining the concept of existence and
the rule of all knowledge
a is a
a thing is itself existence is identity
now all she said was nonsense okay a isa
we talked about that the other day is
absolute nonsense the
identity the law of identity and then
you have the law of non-identity which
is a not equal b
i mean it's all nonsense now what we do
in science we have to define what an
object is and we have to define what
existence is once we define those words
we can start doing physics okay and so
some people confuse me with ayn rand and
those that do simply have not figured
out how different my stuff is from what
ain't
proposed
an object is that which has shape
existence is physical presence physical
means object presence means location and
object that has location exists by
definition and as you can see there's no
uh provision in that definition nothing
there's nothing in the specification of
that definition that requires belief or
an observer if something has is a if you
have an object that would just shape and
it has location it exists by definition
if god wants to exist first he's got to
be an object got to be a thing and then
that's not sufficient either he's better
have location there had better be
distance between god's chest and mind
there should be a straight line of
direction between god and me no matter
where no matter what dimension god
wishes to hide in okay
so let's go with the conclusions here
for this follow okay
conclusions high school college
education what is that it's known as
brainwashing what they're going to be
doing is you're going to be learning by
road you read a book
maybe you even run an experiment at lab
it doesn't matter but they're going to
coach you on what to believe okay and um
what's the problem the problem is that
all that's accompanied by irrational
explanations
and they don't care about mechanisms
they haven't figured out any of the
invisible intangible mechanisms they
dismiss that as philosophy as opinion
and i can summarize it by saying you
can't teach an old dog new tricks
no it's easier for an eight-year-old to
understand uh for example what i'm
proposing okay because
his mind has not been polluted
so a little boy who might be more
[Music]
predisposed to understand a new theory
than an old dog you know who's gone to
high school in the in college especially
a phd who has to get an advisor for his
thesis
that guy is not going to change so i see
the other way around then this uh
british fellow i'm saying that um if
you've got a phd oh man you've gone
through the whole machinery
they've been conditioning you for quite
a while you know so if i go in there and
say look i'm going to erase the uh
scientific method that you inherited
from the 17th century
he's not even going to listen to me